british supermarkets including iceland
and tesco are threatening to stop using
brazilian agricultural products
if the country passes a law expanding
property rights for squatters on public
land
environmental campaigners warned that
the law will encourage deforestation
as it would reward land grabbers in the
amazon rainforest who occupy properties
illegally well joining me now is
iceland's managing director richard
walker
richard thank you so much for talking to
us this afternoon why did you sign this
letter
well i think the the scale of the crisis
the urgency of the crisis cannot be
overstated uh last year alone there was
a size
of virgin rainforest burnt down in
brazil six times
the size of london and this legislative
package
that's going through the brazilian
parliament at the moment
will open up tens of millions more
hectares
of amazon rainforest uh to be uh burnt
and chopped down and also very
importantly it'll open up
indigenous lands for development and
exploitation as well
people who defend this bill say that
actually it's
going to so it will allow land that has
been illegally occupied
from 2014 to be bought so they argue
that people who um small-scale farmers
for example
can clarify title deeds to land meaning
that they can buy
the land that they're on if they've been
illegally um
squatting on it if that's what you want
to call it um title deeds are such an
issue
and small-scale farming is so difficult
do you not think that we should be
getting involved in something like this
from over here well i think this is
humanity's problem because
um at some point in the not too distant
future within a matter of years
the amazon rainforest will turn from a
net
carbon sink to a net carbon emitter
which will have catastrophic
uh consequences for all of humanity and
therefore
the best thing we can do right now is to
stop chopping it down
um but we also of course need to need to
protect
indigenous rights and local land holders
and we work alongside greenpeace quite
closely
and have taken um soundings from wwf as
well
and what what we're told um is that this
is very much about the bolsonaro
government and his cronies uh
taking a land grab to the amazon and
shifting the baseline
away from um those people who are the
indigenous rights holders to the land so
what are the indigenous groups saying
about this
well um i i think there's been
well-documented reports of uh abuses and
land grabs
in um in the amazon um and of course
as a british supermarket sector it's
it's incumbent on
us to take responsibility for our own
supply chains we are having direct
impacts
on these rights abuses because we sell
chicken and pork that has been fed on
soy
which comes from the amazon and uh we
cannot be sure no supermarket can
um that that soy is deforestation free
and therefore
we really are reaching an end point now
um
where we have to say enough is enough
and uh if they won't listen to us like
they did a year ago and they and they
stopped the legislation going through
parliament then
um because money talks but if they won't
listen to us again then
i think we do have to consider um an
option of a moratorium
on brazilian soy what you're talking
about is pretty dire
the situation there don't you think
you've already reached that point
where the supermarkets should say enough
is enough we're not going to deal with
you
potentially yes um but i think you know
a boycott if you like is is not the way
to go a moratorium
um potentially is but it's not a light
switch we can flick
these are proper uh systemic problems
that require systemic
um solutions and therefore we need to
work with the uh commodity traders like
cargill as well
and work on segregation of supply with
them
and so that potentially we can look at
other sourcing options from south
america or america
or indeed europe at the moment it's
impossible to segregate because
um the traders aren't choosing to
to do so um so yes i think drastic times
do call for drastic measures and we do
need to
um look very closely at the situation
and take
what do everything we can to try and
stop this this environmental tragedy but
also
um this local tragedy as well what do
you think
jai bolsonaro is going to make it this
letter if he even takes any note of it
of
notice of it at all i think a year ago
you know it did surprise me because
letters are easy to sign right but
action is
is very different but actually money
talks and
um the biggest market for uh brazilian
soy is europe and and china increasingly
um but if if a lot of the end buyers of
this product are saying we don't we
don't want to be complicit
in uh amazon destruction anymore um then
they have to sit up and and take notice
uh like they did a year ago and
hopefully like they will next week as
well
why are they trying it again then
i don't know um and i'm certainly no
domestic uh
expert on brazilian um policies but it
is odd
and certainly completely at odds with
the rhetoric
um of the bolsonaro regime
last week when at a meeting of world
leaders uh virtually with president
um biden they pledged to halt
deforestation and
do lots of things to improve um the
local environment in the amazon
this will have the exact opposite um
effect
uh tens of millions of hectares of
tropical rainforest will be destroyed
which of course is not just a problem
uh for the animals and the fauna and
flora that live there
um but of course for global rainfall
patterns and
and indeed climate change as well
richard walker md of iceland thank you
so much for talking to us
thank you